so as you probably know Trump care 1.0
failed Trump care 2.0 failed and then
last week we learned about Trump care
3.0 probably the most depraved and
disgusting version of all of these
Obamacare replace and repeal and replace
ideas over 30 million people expected to
end up without health care if this bill
were to pass which includes not only a
repeal of most aspects of Obamacare it
also adds this vulture capitalists
provision where for-profit insurance
companies can squeeze even more money
out of people especially people with
pre-existing conditions or people who
get sick after getting insurance and of
course out of seniors often on fixed
incomes and it seemed like this had a
real shot at passing but then we learned
over the weekend that Republican John
McCain wasn't having it we learned that
Republicans Senator Rand Paul wasn't in
favor for the wrong reasons right but
still he was against it
and it was not looking good all of a
sudden for Trump Care 3.0 so now
Republicans in the Senate have made some
changes to try to once again ram this
thing through by September 30th needing
only 51 votes instead of the 60 that
they would need after that date and one
of these revisions that Republicans have
made is basically a bribe to some of the
states including the state of Alaska
Alaska senator Lisa Murkowski is one of
the knows she was one of the big big ly
publicized knows from last time right
and she is set to be a no this time once
again and Alaska as well as Arizona and
Kentucky would get more federal funding
for Medicaid and other health care
provisions in the original version of
Trump Care 3.0 those states were going
to see declines in funding so first of
all I believe the term bribe is
completely correct here this is a gift
of money meant to persuade someone else
to act in one's favor you weren't going
to vote for it because your state was
going to get reduced funding well here's
some money for you so that now you'll
vote for it in favor of taking money
away from other people who aren't
getting what I would call
a sweetheart deal as a result of one of
these bribes I think that the term bribe
is very accurate here yeah especially
because it was a long shot and everyone
knew that and while Lisa Murkowski and
also you can throw in Susan Collins in
there as well everyone assumed that they
weren't going to vote for this bill
because of the same objections that they
had to the last ones that very simple
there's no pre-existing conditions
coverage guaranteed and that it would
cancel the Medicaid expansion so you can
kind of assume that they were on the
same boat as Rand Paul and John McCain
yeah Republicans are trying to do
whatever they can to make sure that at
least it has a chance yeah and the the
reason why at first glance it seemed
like this thing had way more support is
because the threshold for passage was 51
instead of 60 so it's not that the bill
drastically changed it's not that tons
of people who were opposed to it now are
in favor of it it's that the threshold
was 51 51 votes was was it and this this
also when you think about this money
right that's being offered to these
other states this means that the bill
sucks but that Republicans are fine
voting for it
they don't actually need the money the
Republicans who are not receiving a
bribe
you can argue are just as immoral as the
ones that might be receiving it because
they're saying yeah this is gonna crush
health funding for many health programs
in my state but I'm fine with it I don't
need even need a bribe I don't care
about the health care repercussions I
care about the political optics and they
want to be able to check off hey we
repealed Obamacare that's arguably as
bad as getting the bribe the fact that
they don't care what the health outcomes
are in their states and I don't feel
like John McCain who is one of the key
votes on this is going to be susceptible
to it because even if he does survive
this bout with brain cancer this is
going to be his last term in the Senate
so does he really want this to be his
legacy especially when he calls for
going back to regular order and having a
procedure of going through hearings and
committees and all this guy I hope not I
really hope not
and there are some senators like John
McCain and Lisa Murkowski who seemed to
be saying hey let me evaluate the actual
repercussions of this bill on the people
in my state and I'm going to decide what
to do based on that and then you have
Republicans coming to them and saying
hey will exempt your state from the
crushing funds reduction so that you'll
agree to do the bill but
your state is going to get more money
for health care programs that is not
government for the people that this is
the furthest thing from government for
the people and a really funny but also
really scary moment around this was on
Fox News Sunday yesterday about
pre-existing conditions we know that
people with pre-existing conditions
could easily end up paying more if Trump
care 3.0 were the were to pass and Fox
News's Chris Wallace got the White House
director of legislative affairs mark
short to admit that yeah some people
might pay more if they have pre-existing
conditions after really making him
flummox here's just a minute of video
from yesterday's Fox News Sunday and the
guy it seems like he kind of has no
choice but to admit that yeah you might
pay more if you have free of
pre-existing conditions under Trump Care
3.0 that's a loophole big enough to
drive a tank through Chris those are two
separate questions do you want
Washington DC choosing the rates all
across the nation for all sorts of
factors that's a different question than
guaranteeing pre-existing conditions the
bill guarantees pre-existing conditions
no you're correct it doesn't it just
says that they have to ship forgive me
sir
it it says that all they have to do is
get a federal waiver that they have
adequate and affordable coverage without
ever explaining what adequate and
affordable coverage is that's not a
guarantee adequate and affordable
coverage we guarantee to every one of
those states that apply I think it but
what's the definition of adequate and
affordable and what does it mean when a
state can raise premiums state data says
again that is a separate question and if
do you want Washington DC dictating
that's the country what those rates are
for everybody regardless of what it is
what good is insurance coverage if you
can't afford to because you're also
providing additional financial support
to those states so they can make sure
those rates stay low for all different
individuals in all different classes
including those with pre-existing
conditions Chris well there is no
statement as to how much that's going to
be and in fact there's it says states
can raise premiums for coverage for
pre-existing conditions without any
guidelines there's no question it's
gonna be higher in some states than it
is under Obamacare there's gonna be some
states hire some states lower you want
Washington DC see if you got
pre-existing conditions in a state where
it's higher you're out of luck
satella Chris you're not necessarily out
of luck that means Chris Wallace is
right and the this is the truth right
you can repeat the talking points and
mark short is good at repeating the
talking point do you want the government
deciding what rates are going to be all
over the country do you want for-profit
insurance companies deciding that
they're gonna raise the prices on people
with pre-existing conditions it's a
question of what you want that he's
right about and it really depends on
your philosophy as to whether health
insurance is supposed to be operating in
a free market where people can decide
well this is like a product whether you
can or can't afford it it's like a new
new luxury sedan or is health insurance
something that we need to say no it's
not supply and demand in the free market
we need to treat it differently and
actually that debates gonna happen
tonight on CNN Graham and Cassidy are
going to argue in favor of their bill
yeah against Amy Klobuchar Democrat and
Bernie Sanders obviously opposed to it
as well yep but is it really a good
political move I wonder because I think
they're flailing on their own they don't
need someone arguing in favor of keeping
the affordable care act and even going
further to smash it into the ground it
strikes me the debate it sort of strikes
me as just political theater because
whether or not it passes in two days or
however many days it's going to be is
not really going to depend on the
opinions of people who watch the debate
on CNN tonight and I love that we're
having this debate I think it's great to
have the debate but the truth is we know
what the repercussions will be so the
only influence that the debate could
have is if people fall for the optics of
what is said to defend the bill right
seeing it on an even platform as if
these ideas are just as good as one
another yeah but I wonder if it could
raise poll numbers for this meal if if
it's argued that it's going to help out
the states and you know it's less
government interference and those poll
number increases could translate to more
votes it's possible I'm just some so
skeptical about it I'm just so skeptical
that that's going to happen but I'm
gonna watch the debate I think it'll be
interesting as far as Rand Paul I
mentioned Rand Paul is opposed to the
bill he's opposed to it because he
opposes the Block Grant system and for
different reasons then I think the Block
Grants are a terrible idea I think the
Block Grants are a terrible idea because
they're going to be smaller
the amount of subsidies that Obamacare
has and they're not going to work as
well but I'll take Rand Paul's
opposition right it's not the enemy of
my enemy is my friend it's not Rand Paul
is a great progressive voice it's just
if Rand Paul is one of the votes that
prevents this from becoming the law then
that's absolutely fine the messages
don't stop contacting your senators we
don't know what will happen yet they're
coming for your health care keep calling
your elected officials the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad